(audience claps and cheers)
It's time for Drew's News.
Your daily dance across the good news rainbow.
And with me at the desk is my little pot of gold.
Rossie Ross Mathews.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi, everybody.
Top of the mornin' to ya.
Well we're kickin' off the top of the morning
with some news with brews.
USA today reports that beer
is getting better for you kind of.
More and more breweries
are adding electrolytes to their brews.
So you're gonna start seeing new beers infused
with chia seeds, bee pollen, minerals, B vitamins
and Mediterranean sea salt.
And I mean, you could rock one of these after a long hike.
I mean, what are they not...
This is just ridiculous.
Yeah, I know.
They're tryin' to find an excuse to drink more beer
and I'm not buying it.
I don't like beer because to me
it tastes like pennies.
It's not for me.
Oh yeah.
I know what you mean.
But if someone told me that like a Pinot Grigio
is something I could grab after the gym,
then, you know, I'd bench squat a dumbbell.
I don't know.
I don't know about working out
but it sounds like a motivator.
I actually love beer and I love the taste of it.
So...
For real?
I love it.
I can't even imagine going to like a ball game or anything
and I even drink non-alcoholic beer sometimes.
It too is like a healthy beer.
The only beer that I can have is when I went
to a Dodger's game that's all they had was beer.
And I put like ice in it. (laughs)
Matthew McConaughey does the same thing.
It worked for him.
Oh my, God.
That's another thing Matthew McConaughey
and I have in common.
Exactly.
We're basically the same person.
All right, listen to this next story, Drew.
The New York post reports scientists say
that your happiness in your marriage could
be directly connected to your genes.
And I'm not talkin' Levi.
The University of Arkansas studied
the CD38 gene in 70 couples and found
that those with something called the CC variation
we're more likely to feel grateful for their partner
and to trust them better over long-term.
And people with other variants, they're not doomed.
They just might have to work harder
at things like gratitude, trust, and forgiveness.
So do you think that there's a gene
that makes you better at relationships?
I don't have it if there is one.
(all laugh)
I don't.
But you know and also if it's genetics
you can look at my entire family history
and they weren't great at relationships either.
So I kind of like, I believe this story.
I don't know.
I don't buy it so much.
Really?
Yeah but I also am like not qualified (laughs) at all.
(all laugh)
Let's go study some science Rossie
and we'll come back
with our own hypothesis and observation.
I'll go read a book and get back to you, okay?
I can tell you this.
I'm loving our relationship.
Oh God.
I'm in this for the long haul, dear.
Me too.
Yeah.
I'm really happy.
'Cause we're not sleeping together too.
Oh yeah.
That helps.
Yeah well yeah stay tuned for sweeps.
No.
(both laugh)
I love you.
See this is why.
Okay we've been locked up alone for way too long.
Is this pigeon hot or not?
Say what?
No I'm serious.
The New York Post reports that there's
a hot pigeon in the city.
Wow.
Comedian, Shelby Lorman tweeted a pic
of this foxy foul and it's gone viral.
Science writer, Rosemary Moscow weighed
in to say this bird is actually part pigeon,
part dove formerly known as the Treron vernans.
I'm vernans for this pigeon.
And what I needed to know
is where did she get those pink shoes?
Do you remember?
This reminded me of the hot duck
in Central Park last year.
That was the big trend.
Look that one.
Oh my God.
Yeah everyone was like following that bird forever.
That duck could compete on "RuPaul's Drag Race."
Maybe you'll see it next season.
(happy music)